so the country's safety to the treasury
has assured me that there has been a
restoration of the normal Protocols of
interaction I will hold on to that
because it is vital that the Scottish
government and the Welsh government and
my colleagues and Wales in Northern
Ireland are just as livid about this as
I am I might add and that we are
properly engaged with to ensure that we
can put forward the concerns and the
views of members of parliament and
particularly constituents such as those
of Mr Ewing that she's put to me today
and brief supplementary Paul Sweeney
thank you Deputy for uh presenting
officer
um the deputy first semester has
mentioned this engagement but I was
disappointed to learn recently there's
been minimal engagement from Scottish
ministers on the development of the UK
National shipbuilding strategy and the
refresh of that with the deputy first
Minister please commit to having the
Scottish government engaging fully with
that strategy given that we are the
second biggest purchaser of vessels in
the public sector outside the minister
defense and we need to get this right
when those vessels are awarded to Turkey
is a failure for Scottish industry
I'm very happy to commit to
um to Dialogue on any aspect of strategy
that affects the industrial base of
Scotland or any other question in
Scotland but I respectfully point out to
Mr Sweeney there has not been a
functioning United Kingdom government
for the best part of 12 months it
literally has not functioned interaction
has been appalling dialogue one way
there has been no decision making coming
back from the UK government and what
decision making they've undertaken as Mr
Sweeney and I will agree in the mini
budget was catastrophic so I hope we've
got some degree of functioning
government in the United Kingdom
government to allow us to advance the
very legitimate issue that Mr Sweeney
puts to me this afternoon question
number six Fulton McGregor thank you
Scottish government what support it is
providing to businesses in the
hospitality sector and wait for the
recovery from the covid-19 pandemic and
the cost of living crisis
Minister Martha the hospitality sector
has voted to Scotland's economy we
provided over 4.7 billion pounds in
support to businesses during the
pandemic including across the tourism
and Hospitality sector and are closely
monitoring impacts of the course crisis
we're also establishing a tourism and
hospitality industry leadership group to
drive sustainable long-term recovery we
maintain competitive non-domestic rates
delivering the lowest non-domestic based
poundage in the UK for the fourth
consecutive year supporting a package of
non-domestic rates released worth 801
million pounds and light of increased
pressures and limited powers we will
continue to press the UK government for
support Phil McGregor yeah thank the
minister for that response during the
recent October recess I was invited to
meet with a number of Pub owners from
Copper Ridge Main Street who expressed a
real concern about the viability of
their businesses in the short term due
to the cost of living crisis Rising
energy costs and changes in Behavior
fall in the pandemic one of these the
aiding group who employ nearly 100
people in my constituency were also in
the National newspaper this weekend the
minister might have seen that they are
calling on the chancellor to cut vat
immediately offer rates assistance and
provide some form of recovery funding
with the minister agree with these calls
on the UK government and lend his voice
to them
the presiding officer we understand that
businesses such as the eding group
operating and filtering McGregor's
constituency continue to face
significant challenges including the
longer term impact of the pandemic and
cause crisis and we do not underestimate
the scale of these challenges that's why
my colleague Deputy first Minister wrote
to Jeremy Hunt to a new Chancellor on
19th of October to re-emphasize the need
for targets and support for households
and businesses funded by windfall gains
in the energy sector and seeking Clarity
on the support that will be available
from April 2023 we will continue to work
with businesses in Scotland to press the
UK government for a range of measures to
help ease the current pressures
including on vat and Recovery support
we've supplemented the Douglas Lobster
thank you president sir the audit
Scotland report
um called on Scotland's Financial
response response to covert this year
stated that 100 of the 4.5 billion of
Barnett consequentials related to
business support was allocated but can
the minister tell me how much of the 4.5
million was only located to funds but
not spent and is that money now
available to help businesses who are
struggling right now minister
um we have committed all corporate
consequentials for business support that
we received during a pandemic to support
businesses I missed some of the detail
of the members questions about what
we're happy to consult the official
report and get back to him in writing if
it was anything I missed in the points
that you made and question seven for
children
thank you Deputy presenting officer to
ask the Scottish government what support
it is providing to small businesses
through the cost of living crisis Mr
Richard Lockett we understand the
challenges facing small businesses which
have been exacerbated by the economic
upheaval caused by the UK government in
recent weeks we have in place an
existing package of non-domestic rates
released work worth over 800 million
pounds which includes the UK's most
generous small business bonus scheme
however the powers and resources
required to tackle this crisis of course
live with the UK government and we will
continue to press them to do everything
possible to help Scotland small
businesses because of Treasury
I thank the minister for that answer and
I refer our members to my entry of the
register of Interest I have already been
contacted by business owners within the
Lothian region particularly in Western
businesses who have been operating for
decades but now find themselves having
to close for good thanks to the perfect
storm of kobit a staffing crisis and now
the cost of living crisis too as we see
this happening across multiple sectors
at once does the Scottish government
share my fear that we may have preserved
our economy through the worth of the
cobit pandemic only to see it hollowed
out by this latest crisis minister
I can assure voice will tell you that we
absolutely share his fears and his
concerns in relation to the impact of
the current cost of living crisis and
Rising energy bills on Scotland small
businesses in Lothian and throughout the
country and I should say that say
foreign myself and some others in the
chamber were at the Asian catering
Awards dinner last night where we
enjoyed only some fantastic Curry and
some good company but we also heard from
numerous small businesses in the
hospitality sets in the catering sector
the reference of the enormous challenges
they are facing at the current time with
rocketing energy bills
bills the ingredients and other costs
and this is a very very serious
situation and the first minister of
course wrote as recently as the 27th of
October to the UK Minister stressing the
urgent need for Clarity on what support
will remain available for non-domestic
consumers brand April and we've
committed to working with the business
sector to explore how businesses can be
supported without energy costs within a
devolved powers and we're supporting
business energy Scotland and businesses
should contact business energy Scotland
for advice and we'll do everything else
within our powers
fairly brief supplementary Bill kid
thank you very much president of many
small businesses in Scotland are facing
substantial pressures as you've been
said so can the minister provide any
update as to the Scottish government's
latest engagement with the UK government
regarding support available to small
businesses to deal with this rising cost
as briefly as possible Minister I just
reiterate Bill Clinton makes many
perfectly perfect points and Pavel
points that the first nurse of course
has just written to the new prime
minister about these issues and we're
await response and hopefully a positive
reply and have no doubt that the deputy
first Minister will address some of
these issues in these forthcoming
statements thank you very much Minister
that concludes portfolio questions we
move on to the next item of business
which is the statement by John Swinney
on the emergency budget review the
deputy first Minister will take
questions at the end of a statement so
there should be no interruptions or
interventions and I call on Jones 20
Deputy first Minister for around 10
minutes please
Scotland is facing a cost of living
crisis a combination of the impacts of
brexit the aftermath of the pandemic and
the energy crisis fueled by Russia's
illegal invasion of Ukraine have since
prices spiraling inflation is at a
40-year high and the pressure on the
finances of households and businesses is
acute
public services are facing demands
entirely legitimate demands to make
significantly enhanced pay offers to
their staff
as a government we have a duty to
respond but our ability to respond is
limited by the inactivity of the United
Kingdom government and the financial
restrictions of devolution
the Scottish government budget is
largely fixed we have no ability to
borrow to increase our day-to-day
spending our Reserve funding is fully
utilized and our income tax powers do
not allow changes to be made during the
financial year
in August we announced that we would
undertake an emergency budget review to
identify every possible Penny to support
the people of Scotland through the cost
of living crisis while maintaining a
pathway to balance the budget
on the 7th of September I set out to
Parliament the first of a hard
prioritization choices already made and
today I provide a further update on our
progress through the emergency budget
review process
since September this crisis has deepened
further the inactivity of the UK
government gave wheat to calamity the
United government's many budgets sent
shockwaves through the markets driving
up borrowing costs for government to
businesses and households
so disastrous was the package of
unfunded and uncosted tax cuts for the
rich that not only did the mini budget
not survive the month but neither did
its Architects the chancellor and the
prime minister
the utterly needless upheaval has
created significant damage for
individuals and great uncertainty for
Scotland's finances
initially the Scottish government was
told that we would receive an additional
660 million pounds through the block
grant adjustment now with the new
Chancellor scrapping the plan to cut the
basic rate of income tax in the rest of
the United Kingdom our funding will be
reduced by 230 million pounds over the
period of the UK spending review
this represents a swing of almost 900
million pounds in the space of less than
a month now under a new prime minister
and a new Chancellor Calamity is giving
way to austerity with deep spending cuts
expected
as members will be aware I had intended
to present the outcome of the emergency
budget review to Parliament last week
but paused that announcement while we
awaited the fiscal statement of the 31st
of October however that date has now
changed to the 17th of November
while I would have preferred to see the
obr forecast and the outcome of the UK
statement prior to publishing this
review I have concluded that we can wait
no longer
scale of the challenge is so severe and
the impacts and uncertainties for people
households and businesses so significant
that the imperative consideration must
be to provide as much stability
certainty and transparency as possible
we now also once again face the prospect
of tax changes from the UK government
it is only right then that we take the
appropriate time and care to consider
any impacts on our budget and devolve
tax policies so I will wait until after
the UK government's next fiscal
statement before deciding on the content
of any tax discussion paper
presenting off that I cannot overstate
the degree of challenge associated with
undertaking this emergency budget review
I have said that I've said before that
in all of my experience now and during
my previous tenure as Finance secretary
there has never been a time of Greater
pressure on the public finances
inflation means that our annual budget
today is worth 1.7 billion pounds less
than when it was published last December
at the same time demand for government
support and intervention is
understandably increasing I must balance
the books but I'm committed to doing so
in a way that prioritizes funding to
help families to back business to
provide Fair pay Awards and to protect
the delivery of Public Services this
emergency budget review delivers on
these objectives
this government is determined to enhance
pay and target support to the lowest
paid where possible as a crucial part of
our response to the cost of living
crisis
this support includes offers in the
region of seven percent for Frontline
workers in the local government
non-teacher and NHS agenda for change
workforces this would increase salaries
for the lowest paid staff and agenda for
change by over 11 percent
although some paying negotiations have
still to conclude I have already
committed over 700 million pounds of
additional resources to fund enhanced
pay settlements
I'm grateful for the efforts of
employers and trade unions to facilitate
these vital collective bargaining
processes but to be absolutely clear
every additional penny for pay has had
to be found from existing previously
allocated and agreed budgets elsewhere
within the current finite Scottish
budget we have reached the limit of what
can be done in terms of reprioritization
officer when I set out the initial
package of 560 million pounds in Savings
in 2022-23 I was clear that additional
savings would still be required
today I have published an emergency
budget review that sets out a further
615 million pounds in savings
this includes 400 million pounds from
reprioritization of spend within Health
and Social care to provide a fair pay
offer for NHS staff and to meet the
extraordinary pressures from inflation
and demand as the service begins to
recover from the pandemic
this has included re-facing some social
care spending in line with expected
spending profiles and repurposing spend
in other areas such as mental health
despite this we continue to progress our
work to deliver a national Care Service
as well as commitments to Fair work and
adult social care and we continue to
provide overall increases to mental
health spending as well as delivery of
dementia learning disability and autism
services and cross-cutting Trauma work
these are extraordinarily difficult
choices which no government wishes to
have to make but the full balance of
Health and Social care re-prioritization
will remain within the portfolio
a further 33 million pounds of resource
savings and 180 million pounds of
capital reductions have also been made
including reducing our marketing
expenditures to below pre-covered levels
taken together these decisions and those
already set out in September total
almost 1.2 billion pounds
they are not decisions we would wish to
make but in the absence of additional
funding from the UK government they are
decisions that we are compelled to make
the insurer path to a balanced budget
whilst also prioritizing Fair the public
sector pay offers and recognizing that
this is critical to the delivery of key
Public Services
this government will also always do what
we can to support those most affected by
the cost of living crisis
I can confirm that we have identified
and allocated the resources required to
double the value of the December
Scottish Trail bridging payment
benefiting around 145 000 school-aged
children registered to receive free
School meals
to double the fuel and Security fund to
20 million pounds to increase funding to
local authorities for additional
discretionary housing payment support to
mitigate the UK government's benefit cap
as fully as possible within our devolved
powers
to introduce a new 1.4 million pounds
Island cost crisis emergency fund to
introduce new payment break options to
help protect those who have taken
control of debt through the highly
successful debt Arrangement scheme and
to implement reforms to remove cost
burdens for the most financially
vulnerable
in our efforts to support business we've
also looked closely at regulation and
how we can make it easier for businesses
to thrive and we've used today's review
to set out a range of improvements after
extensive engagement with business
organizations industry groups and
individual businesses and including
industry Summits on energy and financial
services we will arrange we will
introduce a range of measures set out in
the emergency budget review today and
those include building on the additional
300 000 pounds provided to business
energy Scotland this year by doubling
the Energy Efficiency cashback element
of the loan and cash back scheme to
twenty thousand pounds protecting the
small business bonus scheme the most
generous scheme in the UK which takes
over 111 000 businesses out of rates
altogether and establishing a Joint Task
Force with kosla local authorities and
our regulator agencies in business to
consider the differing impacts of
regulation on business
providing a presenting officer alongside
our counterparts in Wales and Northern
Ireland we have repeatedly called in the
UK government to do more given the
considerably greater flexibility
available to the UK government
the first Minister reiterated these
calls to the latest prime minister
highlighting the essential need to
provide further targeted financial
support to low-income households
urgently provide Clarity on what support
will remain available for both
non-domestic consumers and households
following the early end to the energy
price guarantee next march and to make
additional funding available so that
devolve governments can support people
provide Fair public sector pay uplifts
and protect Public Services
the first Minister has also reiterated
our deep concern about the risk of
Social Security benefits not being
increased with inflation in April
a permanent 25 pounds uplift to
Universal Credit should be introduced
now alongside the reversal of the
two-child limit for Universal Credit and
tax credits and the abolition of the
benefit cap we've been clear that an
enhanced windfall tax should fund the
support in place of increased borrowing
or spending cuts
we are now anticipating a package of
eye-watering cuts and tax rises in the
Autumn statement that will be evident to
all members that the emergency budget
review has involved extremely difficult
decisions
even when such decisions need to be made
quickly as is the case now I believe it
is essential that we use the best
available evidence and also be as
transparent as possible
to that end I would like to thank the
members of our expert panel for the
consideration and advice that they have
provided over recent weeks and which I
also published today
panel has assessed the Outlook that
faces the Scottish government in its
budget and advised the government to
proceed with caution to achieve its
objectives in these difficult days
in addition I published a new analytical
report on the impact of the cost of
living crisis in Scotland alongside a
high-level summary of The Evidence
around the equality and fairness impacts
of the emergency budget review measures
the outlook for 2324 and Beyond is
clearly even more difficult than when we
set out the result resource spending
review earlier this year and measures
for efficiency and reforms and the
delivery of our public services will be
even more important nonetheless I can
assure Parliament that this government
remains firmly committed committed and
focused on continuing to support our
Public Service recovery from the impacts
of covered on tackling and reducing
child Poverty of taking forward our Net
Zero Ambitions and supporting strong and
sustainable growth in our country
Frank
thank you Deputy foreign
statement I know we've slightly overrun
but I still intend to allow around 20
minutes four questions after which we'll
need to move to the next item of
business I would though encourage
members to and indeed the cabinet
secretary to be as succinct as possible
in questions and answers and for those
who haven't already done so um could you
please press the request to see speak
buttons if you wish to ask a question I
now call on Liz Smith
uh thank you Deputy presiding officer
can I thank the cabinet secretary for
prior site and can I also acknowledge
the difficult circumstances in which the
Scottish government finds itself some of
them obviously are international some of
them have been domestic and I fully
acknowledge that part of the difficulty
is the timing of the forecast and of the
budget these difficulties are
substantial for the cabinet secretary
and I fully understand why he can't say
a bit more about tax policy just now now
the cabinet secretary is always
challenging the opposition parties quite
rightly so to come up with budget
suggestions of their own so here is one
and he refers to this at the bottom of
page two and that is regarding Health
and Social care can I ask the cabinet
secretary does he really think that now
is the appropriate time for his
government to be proceeding with a
national Care Service bill which has
drawn so much criticism from virtually
every stakeholder and which audit
Scotland is predicting to be costing 1.3
billion in pounds secondly he has
outlined further cuts to health to
education to Justice can I ask why there
have been no further cut to the
Constitution budget
and thirdly he's outlined some measures
that he's agreed with business I think
it's on page three but can he tell us
what specific measures will be put in
place to boost productivity which as he
confirmed himself that finance committee
is a serious issue and which undermines
the tax taken Scotland Deputy first
minister
the complete sentence that Elizabeth was
trying to get out at the beginning of
her um a state of our contribution was
to acknowledge the difficulties created
for me by the decisions of the United
Kingdom as well as the timing decisions
so I think we should just um
allow me allow me allow me to just
complete that sentence for uh Liz Smith
in relation to the National Care Service
it is up a situation where we have a
very high level of delayed discharge
within our hospital system which is
creating enormous strain in the delivery
of National Health Services we have to
recognize and acknowledge the necessity
of reform because the current
arrangements are not working we
therefore have to take the steps to
establish a national care service for
two reasons to ensure that members of
the public are assured in all parts of
the country about the quality and the
range of care that will be available to
them and secondly to ensure that we are
able to support the sustainability of
the National Health Service that is why
that expenditure is required now on the
Constitution budget and I I suspect what
that was code for was expressing the
commitment of the government to spend 20
million pounds on a referendum on
Independence I'd point out to Elizabeth
Smith that expenditure does not arise in
this Current financial year and it's
this Current financial year that I am
wrestling with in its to its greatest
extent and lastly in relation to
productivity I've announced a set of
savings that have been made here today
I'm also at the same time protecting
very very significant levels of public
expenditure in skills in our
universities in our College sector to
ensure that we can invest in developing
the capability of individuals in our
society to maximize their economic
contribution but what would be the
biggest single thing that would help
productivity in this country is if we
had a sensible approach approach to
population growth and migration and that
has been abruptly halted for us by the
photo the total Folly of brexit so if I
can appeal to Liz Smith and the
conservatives about anything the health
secretary points out social care the
social care sector has lost thousands of
employees because of brexit so we need
to have a sensible discussion about
migration because the the behavior of
the conservative government especially
of the Home Secretary in recent days is
directly undermining productivity in the
Scottish economy
I would I would encourage the cabinet
stage to ignore secondary interventions
either from his own brains or indeed the
opposition benches are called Daniel
Johnson
Deputy presiding object can I thank the
cabinet secretary for advanced sight of
his statement and where there are
additional measures on the cost of
living can I welcome them but there is
no doubt the chaos emanating from the UK
government make a challenging situation
that much more difficult but in turn I
think that underlines the need for
clarity and transparency from
governments be they Scottish or UK so
can I ask proportionately which
portfolios have the largest savings to
make against the budget passed earlier
this year in order to achieve the 1.175
billion pounds worth of cuts announced
as confirmed by the fiscal Commission in
paragraph 34 of their May forecast the
Scottish government had planned to carry
forward 279 million pounds from this
year's budget to next and 250 million
pounds to 24.25 using the reserve is
that still the case and if not how have
those sums been allocated and what are
the impacts on next year's budget in the
following and I'm sure the cabinet
secretary agrees that we must all
tighten our belt but I know that the
cabinet secretary for external Affairs
has traveled to eight countries in as
many months clocking up almost 22 000
air miles so what cost control measures
are being applied to the expenditures of
members of the government and civil
servants Deputy first Minister and the I
I think the um the steps that the
government is taking about Clarity and
transparency I think are evident by the
fact that I'm here today and that I
appeared before the finance committee
several weeks ago on the subject that I
session chaired by um Mr Johnson
and I also appeared at in Parliament in
early September to explain openly the
changes in the choices that I was making
so I think on the question of
transparency this government is
delivering on what would be expected of
the uh but by the public what I've tried
to do I've not approached this from the
perspective of applying uh a random
reduction across portfolios what I've
had to do is to look at this very
Advanced stage in the financial year
what options remain available to me to
reprioritize spending and in some areas
of government activity there is more
scope to do that than in others in the
case of the changes in relation to
Health and Social care I was absolutely
clear with the um with the health
secretary and the health portfolio that
whatever savings we were able to
identify would be retained within the
Health and Social a portfolio to support
the very strong payoff for this they
made particularly for low-income staff
in relation to the reserve we've carried
forward the um the resources from the
last Financial year into this year that
we planned we obviously the budget for
next year was predicated in the resource
spending review on a carryover from this
year to next year I have yet to identify
those resources that remains a an
ongoing challenge before the end of the
financial year and I'm still working to
ensure I can balance the budget this
year which is my statutory duty to do so
and lastly on the question of the
international engagement of the
government with a government that we
can't be insular we've got to be in
contact with the rest of the world I'm
quite sure it's really important it's
really important that we maintain that
dialogue the Prime Minister was the
Prime Minister was being criticized just
yesterday for not going to cop27 I'm
delighted he's now going so I think
International dialogue is essential for
every single government including the
Scottish government
[Applause]
could I encourage members not just to
listen to the questions but also to
listen to the answers can I now call
Alex call Hamilton to be followed by
case Gibson
hey thank you very much Deputy presiding
officer make no mistake we're here in
large part because the declamatist
decisions by the conservative government
they've added hundreds of pounds to
people's mortgages and it is
unforgivable that's why we need a
general election but the choices this
government have made are manifestly
wrong as well irrespective of when that
20 million pound is allocated for we're
still spending Civil Service time and
money on the production of
constitutional papers 17 million pounds
on National testing every year and up to
a billion pounds on the ministerial
takeover of social care all the while
councils are being squeezed to the Pips
long covered sufferers are a bit
continue to struggle without and 38
million pounds is being stripped from
Mental Health on this last Point can I
ask the deputy first minute to say
what's changed in this severity of the
national Mental Health crisis that he
can find that level of money to cut from
the mental health budget Deputy first
minister so let me address two
particular points that Mr Cole Hamilton
raises first of all in relation to local
authorities local authorities will be
getting significantly more resources as
a consequence of the reprioritization
exercises I have gone through to support
very strong pay deals that are assisting
local government employees on low
incomes and I'm sure that's something
that Mr Cole Hamilton would welcome in
relation to the question on Mental
Health I acknowledge the significance of
the questions that are under mental
health indeed in my dialogue with the
health secretary we have both been
determined to ensure that we protect the
mental health services as much as we
possibly can do so what has been
announced today will will mean that the
resources allocated to mental health are
not increasing as fast as we had planned
they will still be growing but they will
not be growing as fast as we had hoped
now I'm not going to suggest or to
minimize the significance of that
decision but it comes about because I
have limited options at this stage in
the financial year and it's an
indication
of anything else to any Member of
Parliament of the severity of the
situation that we face in public
expenditure terms that I'm having to
take decisions off that type as I said
in my statement I would prefer not to be
taking those decisions but I have to do
that to fulfill my duty to to balance
our a our resources in a financial year
and also to make sure I can support
employees particularly in low incomes in
dealing with the cost of living crisis
that they all face
thank you presiding officer does the
deputy first Minister agree that the
emergency budget review is Stark about
the difficulties caused by inflation
eroding the Scottish budget The Limited
fiscal powers of this Parliament and the
refusal of the UK Tory government to
either increase the resources available
to scratch ministers or devolve those
pills necessary to deliver for the
people and communities of Scotland in
these challenging times and can he
advise of his engagement with business
and trade unions throughout the
emergency budget review process Deputy
first Minister on the question of
um dialogue with business and Trade
union trade unions we've obviously taken
forward a number of discussions uh with
business and tribunions I've held
business roundtables myself I I met with
a whole range of trade unions to hear
their views and their perspective on
these questions and it's informed the
conclusions that we've come to Mr Gibson
raises
um a key observation about the limited
scope that I have to take different a
different course of action because the
budget for each Financial year is
largely fixed unless the United Kingdom
government changes its position and
obviously
um I have made the case to the United
Kingdom government to recognize the
unprecedented effect of inflation in
this financial year there has been no
Financial year under the evolution in
which we've come anywhere close to the
inflationary pressures that we are
facing and not Merit it's an
intervention which I've asked the United
Kingdom government to undertake okay
we've got eight further speakers in
seven and a half minutes in this session
so I'm gonna have to speed up both of
the questions and indeed the answers the
deputy first Minister Douglas Livingston
um presiding officer the Scottish
government has received specific baronet
consequentials this financial year for
things like the UK government's housing
support fund however the Scottish
government has not always been
transparent on how this money has been
spent could the deputy first Minister
commit to publishing information on how
the Scottish government has spent all
consequential funding it has received
throughout this financial year Deputy
first Minister well what how
consequential funding works is that the
UK government takes its decisions the
money is transferred to the Scottish
government and they republish an
extraordinary detail or budget plans the
Autumn budget revision and the spring
budget revision to give a complete
picture during the financial year and Mr
Arthur will be going to committee
shortly once the Autumn budget reviews
uh published to explain its contents but
I've also come to Parliament with two
additional substantive Financial
statements in early September and today
or transparently setting out what the
government is doing with all the
resources available to us so amazing to
be followed by Paul Sweeney
hey thank you can the deputy first
Minister confirm that this statement is
based on the assumption that Westminster
will not either increase or decrease our
block grant in the current year 22-23
and if they were to do that in the 17th
of November what would happen Deputy
first Minister there's this statement is
predicated on the fact that we we
receive neither uh an increase in order
decrease in the funds we expect to
receive from the United Kingdom
government that risk is not just
apparent
um on the 17th of November that risk
also extends until the moment at which
the United Kingdom government undertakes
its supplementary estimates the date for
which I am not yet certain and so there
is risk involved in all of this and we
that there could be an upside but
equally there could be a downside but I
have to take decisions to properly set
out the budget choices the Scottish
government is making and if I uh and at
times I have to do that without the
complete picture of information that
ordinary would be available to me both
we need to be followed by Michelle
Thompson thank you Deputy presenting
officer I know the deputy Forest
Minister's comments regarding the
potential impact of the eminent UK
fiscal statement on our devolved tax
policies and his intention to wait until
we hear that statement itself to
consider further discussion on tax but
if I could push him over so slightly on
this there are a number of underutilized
evolved tax options which we should be
fully considering that could generate
Revenue to invest in the areas outlined
today which are stretched so thin so
will this Deputy first minister in
principle it's a comprehensive review of
devolved tax policies within the gift of
the Scottish Parliament falling the UK
government's fiscal statement
well I I have to do that because I have
to take tax rates on an annual basis so
that will be undertaken if there are
particular propositions that Mr Sweeney
would like me to consider I would be
very happy to to receive them in writing
or I could meet with them and hear the
points that he would like to put to me
Michelle Thompson to be followed by
roscrea the cabinet secretary is faced
with two aspects of risk of critical
concern personally the uncertainty
created by chaotic UK government
economic policies and secondly the
undoubted harm about to be inflicted on
the average citizen come the
Chancellor's Autumn statement that the
chancellor has taken advice from George
Osborne the architect of austerity is no
Comfort on either front can the cabinet
secretary therefore indicate the basis
of discussions with the latest UK
Chancellor or indeed if he's been
consulted with him by him at all Deputy
first Minister I've had initial
discussion with the chief secretary the
treasury on the approach to the November
the 17th statement that has not in any
three perform covered substantive
details I have been promised substantive
engagement before the UK statement and
oversee I will make myself available for
any of that dialogue
um at any opportunity growth career to
be followed by Stuart McMillan
thank you further to the answer could I
asked the cabinet secretary what
response they've received from the UK
government to the Scottish government
specific requests that the financial
segment for this current year be
inflation proved
I have not had a positive response to
that yet despite the fact we have asked
for that
um on a number of occasions to Kate
Forbes asked for that issue to be
addressed in the summer before she went
on maternity leave I reiterated that
first Minister has made that point and I
will continue to stress that point
because this as I said in one of my
earlier answers this is a year quite
without precedent of the scale of
inflationary pressures and ordinary if
inflation is two or three percent is not
really going to cause much of a
financial strain inflation at 10 is a
real Financial strain and you know the
criminal justice committee this morning
had evidence from the chief executive of
the Scottish prison service about the
issues that a public service like the
prison service was wrestling with so the
point that Mr Greer makes to me and
which I will be taking to the UK
government is an entirely valid point of
view do you like melon to be followed by
Alexander stew thank you for sending off
so with the key labels to address the
cost of Crisis because loving crisis
story in the hands of the UK government
the Scottish government is severely
constrained in terms of their funding
which is available to it to take action
to support people in Scotland include
migrant number of clay constituency this
clearly shows the deficiencies of the
current fiscal framework does the deputy
first Minister agree with me that the
full Suite of powers available to an
independence government this Parliament
would have been able to more freely deal
with and mitigate the course crisis
Deputy first Minister there are very
clearly constraints from what we are
able to do because our budget largely is
fixed because of the nature of the
arrangements that we we face so Mr
Miller makes the fair and reasonable
point that there are a range of other
powers and responsibilities that could
be used to provide us with much greater
flexibility in addressing the challenges
that we Face Alexander Stewart to be
followed by Jackie Dunbar thank you
Deputy planning officer the deputy first
Minister has announced spending
re-prioritization was 400 million across
Health and Social care portfolios this
includes custom mental health and
Primary Care spending can I ask the
deputy first Minister whether the
Scottish government has carried out an
analysis on the impact of these cuts to
those receiving mental health treatment
or Primary Care funding and where
exactly this money is to be taken away
from Deputy first minister
so as I explained demands to Alec Cole
Hamilton the the issues and what will
vary in different budget lines in
relation to mental health the budget
will not be increasing as fast as we had
hoped and wanted to ensure in relation
to some of the work around about primary
care we will be asking for Reserve
funding that is held by Health and
Social Care Partners to be used as an
early priority rather than it being
retained while further strain is carried
by public funds and I would point out to
Mr Stewart that we're having to do this
because of the severe Financial pressure
applied to us by the mismanagement by
the United Kingdom government of the
public finances and the economy where
inflation has been allowed to to read
rampant across our society so those are
the hard choices that we have got to
address as we deliver on the
expectations of members of the public
and in relation to the impact of members
of the public we have published an
equality assessment which addresses many
issues that Mr Stewart raises with and
as briefly as possible Jackie Dunbar
thank you president officer the rising
cost of living is having a substantial
impact on families across Scotland and
so far the UK government has failed to
provide any certainty to families and
low incomes does the deputy first
Minister agree that the UK government
should be should give a clear commitment
in its upcoming fiscal statement that
social security benefits will be
increased in line with inflation as
before
I think that would help members of the
public facing the acute challenges
obviously we've taken decisions to boost
the support available to families facing
financial hardship and I would encourage
the UK government to do likewise
thank you very much indeed that
concludes the statement we move on to
the next item of business which is the
debate on motion 6523 in the name of
Craig koi or national Care Service
viability I would ask members wishing to
participate to press the respect their
requested speak buttons now or as soon
as possible I would encourage members
who are leaving to do so as quickly and
as quietly as possible and I call on
Craig Hoy to speak to and move the
motion Mr Hoy for up to seven minutes
please